Because I'm a college professor,
I'm going to start with a pop quiz.
(Laughter)
I want you to think of the best
college in the country,
one that you would absolutely
love to get into.
One that would change
your life completely.
OK, do you have it?
I'm guessing if I went
to the audience right now
and asked 100 different people
which college they chose,
I'd hear the same names
over and over and over again.
And that's because we have
a huge problem in higher education.
We say we want colleges
to be more equitable,
more transformational,
more accessible.
But we tend to obsess over
a tiny group of colleges
most of us could never get into.
And it's not because
we aren't smart enough.
It's because there isn't enough
space for all of us.
These schools intentionally cap
the number of students that they accept.
It's why Akil Bello, an advocate
for fairness in college admissions,
calls them something else.
They're not prestigious universities.
They're highly rejective colleges.
(Laughter)
Places like Harvard, Stanford,
Yale, Princeton, MIT.
And I'm not saying these schools are bad.
They're obviously major
research institutions.
But our cultural obsession
with a limited group
of highly rejective colleges
has major consequences.
I'm the first person in my immediate
family to graduate from college.
(Cheers and applause)
And Portland State University,
a regional public university
in Portland, Oregon,
truly changed my life.
(Cheers and applause)
But for a long time,
when someone at a networking event
asked me where I went to college,
I worried that they'd judge my intellect
and my aspirations when I answered.
Now I research higher education
to understand how our perceptions
of which colleges are good
shape important decisions we make
about which schools to fund,
donate to, attend,
and send our children to.
Regional public universities,
or RPUs for short,
are the exact opposite
of highly rejective colleges.
You can spot them because their name
tells you which communities they serve.
Western Colorado University,
Northern Kentucky University,
Eastern Washington University.
In New York, they're the SUNY
and the CUNY schools.
In California,
they're the 23 CSU campuses.
They’re called “normal schools” in China,
“Fachschule” in Germany
and “provincial colleges”
in Canada and Italy.
These are the universities
that train the nurses
who take care of you
when you go to the hospital,
the school teachers
who educate your children
and the small business leaders
that create jobs in your home town.
Regional public universities, or RPUs,
pride themselves on accepting everyone
or almost everyone who applies.
And RPU students are more likely to be
first generation college students
like I was,
students of color, low-income students,
veterans and adults balancing work
and family while going to school.
And RPU students often don't have
the test scores required
to get into a highly rejective college.
Not because they aren't capable,
but because they weren't given
the same advantages as other students.
My mother was a brilliant woman
who had an eighth-grade education,
and she died when she was
just 43 years old
of a totally preventable asthma attack
because she lived in a rural,
remote community
and lacked access to health care.
I grew up in poverty
and my test scores were lower
because I prepared for the SATs
by showing up on test day
with a sharpened number-two
pencil and a calculator,
rather than taking
expensive test prep courses.
People sometimes talk about regional
public universities in negative ways
by calling some “the 13th grade”
or saying, “anyone can get in,”
as if that’s a bad thing.
Or saying they're not real universities.
But shouldn't colleges be judged
by how many people they include
and raise to the same level
of academic excellence
rather than by how many
people they exclude?
By how well they address
the pressing challenges
facing their local communities?
Take Adams State University
in southern rural Colorado.
Thirty-eight percent
of the university’s students are Latinx
and half are first in their
families to go to college.
This is Colorado's most
affordable university,
and it's one of just a few
in the entire country
to offer graduate degrees to students
who are currently incarcerated
and working to change their lives.
It contributes 83.5 million dollars
each year to the local economy.
Regional public universities
like Adams State University
generate more upward mobility
than any other type of college.
But you'll never find it
on a list of America's
most prestigious universities.
And it doesn't get
the funding it deserves.
Ironically, the colleges that already have
the largest endowments
tend to receive the biggest
charitable donations.
Recently, Michael Bloomberg
gave Johns Hopkins University
a donation of 1.8 billion dollars.
And this is an incredibly generous gift.
But before the donation,
Johns Hopkins had an endowment
of 3.8 billion dollars,
and it rejects 89 percent
of all students who apply.
By contrast, Adams State University,
which prides itself by accepting
the top 99 percent of students,
has an endowment of just 63,000 dollars.
Not million, not billion,
63,000 dollars.
Shockingly low.
Now, Johns Hopkins
produces vital research.
But let's imagine, if Michael Bloomberg
had spread that donation
across the 430 RPUs in the country,
each would have received
four million dollars.
Now imagine if your net worth
went from being 63,000 dollars
to four million dollars.
Your life would be
pretty different, wouldn't it?
Unfortunately, the government
only makes this issue worse.
In the United States
and throughout the world,
far more public funding
goes to highly rejective colleges
than to regional public universities.
Because of this, RPUs
have become more expensive,
which hurts low-income students
and has caused student loan
debt to skyrocket.
If I were 18 years old right now,
I honestly don’t know
if I could afford to go to college
given how much tuition has increased
and how little public funding has kept up.
If we really want more low-income
students to go to college,
if we really want equity
in higher education,
we need to put our money
where our mouth is
and fund regional public universities.
Now, many of us have been
on the receiving end
of calls from our alumni association,
and I don't think the ink was dry
on my diploma when my phone rang.
For my generous friends who may have
gone to a highly rejective college,
and don't worry, I'm not mad at you --
(Laughter)
But instead of giving to your alma mater,
which is probably already very wealthy,
consider giving it to the colleges
that really need it.
To the RPUs that truly serve
their communities.
Last year, billionaire
philanthropist MacKenzie Scott
gave 1.5 billion dollars to 73
different colleges and universities
that serve low-income students
and students of color.
Xavier University of Louisiana,
maybe not a household name,
but did you know that they send
more Black graduates to medical school
than any other college in the country?
She gave them 20 million dollars.
And guess what?
That was the largest gift
they had ever received.
And that was true for most
of the schools on her list.
Places like Long Beach City College,
the University of Central Florida,
CSU Northridge.
Many of these schools
are regional public universities
that so rarely get large donations
that her gift was transformative.
There's no better way
to make a difference in higher education
than to give to the colleges
that change the lives
of their students and communities.
But this isn't all about money.
We all have the power
to change the way we think about
and talk about regional
public universities,
or stop people when they
frame them in negative ways.
So when you hear someone saying,
"Oh, anyone can get into that school,"
push them on why that's a bad thing.
You don't have to be rude about it.
You could just say,
"Wow, that's amazing
that that school gives so many people
the opportunity to go to college."
I'm living proof
that no matter where you were born
or how much money your parents have,
you should have the opportunity
to go to a college
that supports your growth
and fosters your dreams.
When we change the way we define prestige
and fund regional public universities,
we will make higher education
equitable once and for all.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)